hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
today we're gonna be taking a look at
the top five things in tech in the build
quality department so I've seen all
kinds of crazy devices like the Casio G
1 and the ThinkPad Toughbook that are
extremely well built because they're
intentionally ruggedized for this video
we will not be including anything that
is intentionally in that ruggedized
department because that would be too
easy
these things that we're gonna be talking
about today are the best build things in
tech in both the ergonomics and the
functionality and a quality department
these things are absolutely all around
just really well built things and you've
probably already seen a lot of the
things on this list if you're curious in
any of them all the links are below
let's get started number five is Gorilla
Glass 2 it's one of the biggest names
sort of every year in this sort of tech
industry when you see the spec sheet and
you've roll down and you see Gorilla
Glass a lot of people just kind of
assume everything is Gorilla Glass but
not all smartphone and tablet glass
panels are created equal it's not
scratch proof but it is subject to a lot
of pressure especially when you drop it
and Gorilla Glass 2 can withstand a lot
more pressure than any other pretty much
any other hardened glass that you use in
a device out there Gorilla Glass one
when it was first introduced by corning
was really really strong but Gorilla
Glass 2 is actually a thinner sheet and
it maintains that strength regular glass
will shatter after about 7,000 pounds
per square inch or psi while Gorilla
Glass has been known to withstand
upwards of a hundred thousand psi so
good stuff throw glass is actually found
in devices pretty much everywhere HTC
phones Motorola phones Nokia phones we
see it all over the place in spec sheets
the iPhone 5 does not use Gorilla Glass
yeah number four in this bill quality
Department is aluminum now there are
plenty of things that are made of
aluminum but we'll use this back throw
here as our example aluminum is often
used in the highest quality built
designs in you know laptops and phones
and just the overall synonymous with
high quality and the phrase unibody
aluminum design which almost everyone
uses all the time isn't necessarily
always literally what it means but
basically if you hear that it's aluminum
unibody it's probably going to be built
very well you can trust that things that
are made of aluminum
and will take a beating they maintain
their shape their structure their
rigidity and their lightweightness when
they're under pressure and definitely
more so than plastic
now that perot happens to also be filled
with aluminum so it's really heavy it's
also really sexy number three is this
guy it's a GoPro I have a full review of
this guy right here in particular the
GoPro Hero 3 coming soon to my channel
so definitely subscribe if you want to
see that but basically the GoPro series
is very well known for its compact
nature and its ruggedness it's not
necessarily built to be beaten and
abused but there are very well aware
when they build this thing that you're
going to be beating and abusing it and
attaching it to crazy things and
dropping it off places and it actually
comes with well you can get for it a
waterproof housing so you can use this
thing underwater you can attach this
thing to a helmet I'm gonna do beating
some pretty interesting things with the
GoPro when I do actually review it
hopefully some things you guys haven't
seen before but the GoPro Hero 3 is just
a hell of a camera and it's got a really
big sensor in it for some reason so
they've gotten a lot of great features
in this tiny little body and it's rugged
last well number two is the HTC One X
now I personally happen to think this is
one of the best-looking phones of all
time I'll include my review down below
the like button but basically this is a
really really really well built phone
the tolerances were extremely tight not
only does it have a Gorilla Glass 2 and
II an aluminum unibody design but it's
actually good-looking
compact nice specs it was a really good
smartphone not very long after it was
released a video was uploaded to YouTube
of the HTC One X hammering and nail into
a 2x4
I can't tell you how many times I
cringed while watching this video and I
would never attempt that with any of my
phones but wow that's awesome and number
one in the most well built tech the most
durable the most rugged the most beastly
yes probably already saw this comment
and it's barely even able to be called
tech but it's the Nokia 3310 this phone
was released in 2000 and it had pretty
average specs for a device that came out
at that time it was also just a basic
device for people who needed a basic
phone because that's what people bought
phones for back then this was a little
bit on the chunky side I'll admit that
it was 22 millimeters thick
it had a 1,000 milliamp hour battery on
the back that lasted months and it had a
display of I believe 84 by eighty four
pixels monochrome display and you could
take an axe to it Nokia nailed it with
the build quality of this phone the
actual shell of it if you drop the phone
might pop off and that's okay because
you can connect it back together and it
continues working because the actual
frame inside of that is pretty much
undestructible there are videos all over
YouTube of attempting to destroy this
thing and there are memes all over the
rest of the internet of people who have
experience with attempting to destroy
this thing you cannot break a Nokia 3310
if you bought one and you wanted to get
rid of it you had to sell it because you
were cursed you can't throw out a
working phone like that the battery life
also happens to last a really long time
wanna set a month I wasn't joking it
literally lasts a month on battery and
you would think that every other phone
that came out during that time was as
durable as the 3310 but nope just the
3310 the Nokia 3310 is officially a boss
and legend has it they're still around
operating beating in the hearts of
cities everywhere
they're awesome so there you go Tech has
been pretty awesome and it's been well
built recently I'll give an honorable
mention shout out to the Oppo find five
unibody well-constructed gorilla glass
on the front steel frame if you want to
check out the review click it I'll just
leave that annotation and also give a
shout out to the Nokia Lumia 920 which
is another recent phone it's a Windows
Phone but it's got a pretty solid build
as well very similar actually to the
fine 5 in its frame it didn't survive
the sledgehammer test that the 3310 did
but i'll tell you what it's a pretty
darn good build call
phone on the chunky side again but nice
I also wanna give a special shout out to
the iPhone 4 and the iPhone 4s which had
a glass front and a glass back and the
shoutout goes to them for being the most
used shattered phones of all time I have
never seen a phone that shattered that
people continue to use I know a lot of
people who use shattered iPhones which
is fun for Apple I guess
interesting yeah yeah so shout out to
them for that either way thank you for
watching have you ever used anything
after it's broken like continued to use
it I have but I try not to and also if
you want to check out any of the things
I mentioned this video I'll have links
to like information about them below
hopefully the Nokia 3310 links don't
break things around them they're pretty
awesome but check out the links and if
you want to check out the rest of the
products feel free to do that yeah
don't buy a 3310 you'll never get rid of
it it's difficult to do that alright
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
guys in the next video